there's this really sinister move  happening right now and it's happening  among the pro-abortion militants and  also the democrats i repeat myself  obviously but where they are they're  they're going after the the pregnancy  the crisis pregnancy center the  pregnancy resource centers these are  people who give choices exactly these  are these are uh just establishments  that are set up to help pregnant women  that's all they give you they give you  diapers they give you counseling they  give you what you need and the democrats  saying let's shut all them down because  if a woman is pregnant we want her to be  desperate and afraid because it's it's  through fear  that she goes to get the abortion the  abortion clinic feeds off of fear